the 90s were very good to me
i got one for the uk one for latin
america and now best actress in the u.s
when you think of the 90s you can't help
but think of melissa really
thank you was a big commercial girl
everyone i was known in second grade as
the rice krispies girl
you are probably wondering how the
darling family got into the sorry state
clarissa was this interesting show cause
it was so popular but it really took off
after the fact and to have a girl lead
was sort of rare at the time still
because salem needs a date really fast
send him someone he truly loved from the
past
what do you think was the magic within
that show what was the magic
it looked the magic was the magic
melissa joan hart i know you have heard
this from so many people over the years
but i we know each other i definitely
know you girl
without a doubt clarissa explains it all
was my jam back in the day
my little six seven-year-old stuff i was
like obsessed if clarissa decorated her
room like this if you wore something
if you said something oh you didn't
paint like black
uh checkerboard on the wall did you if
my parents would have let me it would
have been done but i remember i was like
i need a stop sign i need an exit
i want a ladder on a second story room
yeah except that that was on the first
floor of a studio and sam would lay on
the floor and
throw the ladder up and then get on his
knees and climb in it was only three
rungs
you have been working for a long time
since the age of four
you started out as a model well i did i
did a commercial for a bathtub
toy splashy so my first job was uh
having to um disrobe in front of a crew
and get into a bathtub and i was very
shy about it apparently i booked a lot
of auditions
as a little girl especially with
commercials i grew up in new york
and new york is a very big commercial
town very big soap operas and theater
and so i did a ton of theater i was
known in second grade as the rice
krispies girl
aren't you gonna play our song for it i
kind of forgot it then i was known as
the arnold's bread girl
lifesavers like i did all these amazing
barbie those are the best because
i got to take home a dream house one
time they let me take the dream house
from the set
like so i scored some toys it was good
now who lit that fire in you
to get a start in commercials and
theater and acting
you know it was really the show romper
room which you're too young to know
romper room was a show and it was uh
miss marianne would say
your name in the magic mirror and she
would never say melissa it wasn't a
popular name
and trisha and betty and cheryl and i
realized i did the math and i was like
she's saying the names of the kids that
are sitting in front of her so i need to
get on that show
if i want her to say my name so i said
to my mom i got to be on tv and she knew
somebody who was auditioning in new york
a lot and so she called the mom and
got a manager and i booked my first
audition for the bathtub doll splashy
that is one way of going after and then
it just kind of snowballed from there
like you know it was a lot of
uh like i guess start on an episode of
the equalizer the tv show in the 80s i
did uh you know a lot of center not live
actually anytime they needed a little
girl i was in a skit
saturday live i did a ton of theater i
was the youngest member of the circle
repertory company very young i got to
see um
alec baldwin on stage do prelude to a
kiss
in a small downtown theater in new york
and um
i just i remember meeting christopher
reeves in the audience that night and
just thinking wow my life has been made
i met superman and alec baldwin a
shirtless in front of me and prelude to
a kiss
and i was like 10. and then the 90s come
along
and the 90s were so good to you they
were but what was it about the 90s that
seemed like you were just ready for this
stardom
you know it was all this snowball effect
and like growing up in new york i feel
like there was a difference between new
york actors and la actors la actors were
around a lot more hollywood stuff right
a lot more premieres a lot more
access to people a lot more you could go
to lunch and run into somebody
new york wasn't really like that it was
um the theater and the tv and so it was
very much more a uh
you want to work you just want to work
you know and so
i think that what happened was clarissa
happened
i did three auditions for that and ended
up in orlando for four years so i was
kind of kept out of the hollywood scene
and knowing what that was all about
until i got the show sabrina in my 20s
and i think the 90s just you know i
clarissa was
this interesting show because it was so
popular but it really took off
after the fact because it was on
nickelodeon it was on cable so cable
wasn't a big deal not that many people
had cable and that show really helped
nickelodeon fine and new at the time it
was like sort of game shows and variety
shows and
clarissa was its first real sitcom i
think yeah
and to have a girl lead was sort of rare
at the time still
but on cable to have this show just sort
of
like pick up but slowly build and still
to this day like i feel like it's still
building
and then because of that it
springboarded me into sabrina so i'd had
this successful show that was still
gaining heat after it wrapped and my
mother
um was handed a comic book on a
playground in new york city and it was
the sabrina the teenage witch which is
an archie comic
and they said we think this would be a
great next role for melissa my mom took
it
went to archie comic bought the rights
to it for a dollar took it to viacom
said i want to make a tv movie they were
like let's make a movie for showtime
and then from that my mom kept saying it
would be a great tv show it'd be great
tv show be great tv show
and she had started managing my career
right after clarissa because she didn't
like the offers i was getting after
clarissa she didn't like the direction
she's like she was known on a kids show
and now you want to throw her in these
adult roles
well even though i was 18 she's like i
don't think the people that have
followed her this far
are gonna want to watch her right you
needed a segway in a sense so we wanted
to build a family-friendly programming
block
kind of the way i grew up in the 80s
where there's one tv in the household
and everybody sits down to watch that
television and so my mom
being as smart as she is sold the show
to um
abc and put it in the tgif time spot and
it was just it took off like that
your mom is sharp yeah she is she really
is
you sound like the perfect working duo
right there you in front of this you
know in front of the camera she behind
the scenes was it always like that
throughout your career
it was i mean she was always the
powerhouse behind me i mean if it wasn't
for her i wouldn't be able to go
do auditions you know she was always
sort of managing my career in a way of
like let's do this job let's not do that
job
and picking a path for me and just
managing me
in a way that put me that made sure that
i grew my audience as opposed to turn
them away just because i got older and i
wanted to be
sexier or fancier or whatever it wasn't
always trying to find that great oscar
role it was like
what's the next thing your audience will
watch you in you know
[Music]
i want to go back to clarissa what was
it about that role
that made it the perfect match for you
with clarissa i think that
well the producer really didn't want to
blonde he would he did not want to
blonde he was like absolutely not
blondes can't be
non-conformist cool groovy they're you
know
so smart you know that kind of thing so
i think that that's why i had to
audition so many times for him because
he just couldn't get his head around the
way i looked versus what he had imagined
but i think it was my fast talking kind
of witty you know
i always get told i have to slow down
nobody can understand me i talk too fast
but i think that that's also one of
those things you have to have timing and
i think i had that timing and coming
from theater into sitcom
isn't that big a segue because you still
have to be big and broad and play out to
the audience a little bit
i'm still working on the silent
treatment the question of the moment
is this fun or what why do you think it
made such a big impact with
young girls there's so many different
reasons i hear from people all the time
saying that clarissa got them started in
their fashion careers
um because she was just the wardrobe was
so crazy wild right i can't even
fathom how they put those things
together but also not sexy not like you
see these days not crop toppy and you
know it was like
big baggy keith herring t-shirts tucked
into a belted
dress with leggings and combat boots
yeah just like you know different and it
was very much an east
uh like the east side of new york you
know it was sort of like
this and that's where the wardrobe um
stylist came from
so clarissa had a lot to do with the
wardrobe and i think it had a lot to do
with the fact that her best friend was a
boy and the other characters are boys on
the show
but it was also and this is the part i'm
maybe not too proud of is
it it was one of the first shows where
the kids talked off to the parents a
little bit
where the kids were smarter than the
parents or perceived to be smarter than
the parents even though it's sort of
from a kid's perspective
of course we all think we're smarter
than our parents of course you know
sometimes parents are so dumb
but i think that it's the first time you
really saw that in television nowadays i
think it's gone to a point of being
nasty where i hear my kids saying things
they hear on tv shows and i'm like oh no
no
no you don't talk to me that way you
know yeah ate blood in this house
nope but i feel like it's um it was a
show that was just really smart too
those writers from clarissa went on to
be show runners for friends
went on to be show runners for the
office i mean they they went on to do
big things
what about the fame that you experienced
from that show you
like were catapulted to this instant
fame you know it's funny i actually
never felt that really no because
clarissa started on nickelodeon
on cable and not that many households
had cables but honey you had team
beat you had bob you had i mean every
kind of teen
i feel like that came a little later i
did a people magazine
photo shoot and i was probably 14 when
that happened
but really it didn't feel like that you
know it definitely if it was that i
definitely didn't sense it you know
in new york city's not that many kids
and not that many kids watched
clarissa until later on it picked up
speed i want to say around third or
fourth season and i remember being
recognized on the street people being
like
are you on the show clarissa and i'm
like you watch nickelodeon
okay you know i'm being a little snobby
about it i think the very first time i
ever got recognized i was kind of like
oh i'm sorry you watch you watch
nickelodeon okay
like but look where it got you you took
a break i know and
i'm so proud of it now it's so funny
because i definitely had a sense of like
you see a lot of these pop stars or tv
stars or movie stars
kind of the one thing that made them
they want to push away
the one song that that's their big hit
i've never got i think it's because
people always want it want to talk about
it you're so sick of talking about it
and you and as an artist you want to
keep growing and you want to keep moving
forward and you want to keep
finding new roles or writing new songs
or whatever it is as an artist that you
want to
and you're known for this one thing you
want to disconnect from it so much
until later on when you get older and
mature enough to appreciate it you know
so after clarissa ended you took a brief
you stepped back briefly from hollywood
because you thought you were going to go
finish up at
you know i was going to start in my life
yeah
so what's interesting is the very first
time i remember having a real conundrum
like a real like
at a crossroads was right after clarissa
ended and i was like i am going to
college
because no one in my family had really
gone to college but it was important to
me i'm gonna go to college
and i only applied to nyu i only wanted
to go to nyu i only
knew about nyu and i was looking for my
other career
i'd heard all the horror stories about
child actors they don't last it doesn't
you know develop well and
you know usually have one big role and
you're done and i just
wanted something else and i wanted
options and so college was really
important to me and
immediately i got offered this tv movie
called
family reunion a relative nightmare sure
i'd rock you in my arms and you'd drool
on my dress
well you know i still have a slight
dribbling problem but it was gonna cut
into my first four weeks of school
so i made the really tough decision to
go do the movie
and postpone school until january and i
think then i went to school that
semester
the fall semester and by january of the
next year i was doing a sabrina movie
in vancouver which then translated to i
think it was later on that year
the show i'm doing a tv show so 96
sabrina
happens what do you think was the magic
within that show
what was the magic it listed magic was
the magic i'm gonna put this away the
magical way
excellent hey
i think the thing is these escapist
these um these shows that have these
magical elements to them bewitched in
before me and and i dream of genie they
have this element of wish fulfillment
and
everybody wants to know what would i do
if i had that power so watching 163
episodes of what would i do if i had
that power is exciting
yeah and we were able to sprinkle it in
first of all amazing writing team and
incredible casting and fantastic special
guests and musical elements and
animals we had more animals on that show
than i think anyone's ever had on a tv
stage
ever we had elephants and donkeys and uh
oh my gosh an alligator that almost ate
our puppeteer like we had
a panther and we had i think 2
000 pounds of candy corn come out of a
doorway and
you know just like insane things but
that wish fulfillment element i think
will always hold
for people they love to see that i mean
it's why harry potter is so big and
i think that that's something that
people really gravitate to and
especially because
when times are tough people want
something good to look forward to or
something good to watch or something
light and easy to watch
and that's what we try to give them it
was really well known
i mean what was it about how did you
guys achieve that chemistry was it
natural right off the bat
so what i've learned about chemistry and
acting and i never took acting classes
or anything but i did work with an
acting coach who was really great at
chemistry and i
i figured out that i think i'm really
good at making
chemistry creating chemistry between
myself and others i think that
i set the tone of like a really trusting
person who i'll tell you about me you
tell me about you and we'll have fun
and i'm i'm at work to get the job done
and then go home to my family
and that's always been my thing i'm not
loving being at work all the time but
i'm not hating it i'm having a great
time but i
i think that that creates good chemistry
and creating a loving environment
life's too short to go to work and not
have fun so i like to create a fun
environment on the set this is a crew
that we like
we were a family and we supported each
other and it's like
everyone got to grow so the second
assistant camera guy became the first
camera operator and our first operator
became the dp
and like everyone got to direct and you
know became a nurturing environment for
everybody to grow
i love that after sabrina i mean like
you've been non-stop after sabrina then
you went on to melissa and joe
yeah see
that works yeah because when we're
kissing you're not talking
that show was a really fun one although
i was living in connecticut and so i had
to travel out to l.a a lot so that was
hard on me
personally but um it was such a fun
character that's my favorite character
i've ever played
really she was just such a flawed person
and instead of always being the center
of the you know the mess and trying to
pull it together like sabrina or
clarissa was
mel was the was the tornado yeah and i
got to have so much fun with that she
was a lush she was a [ __ ] she was just
like
just a fun character everyone assumed it
was a kid's show but really it was an
adult show
right and i just had to happen to have
some kids in it but it was a really fun
character to play and i really miss her
opposite though you and melissa and joey
was obviously joey lawrence so what was
that like
being able to work with him well joey
and i had known each other since we were
like six years old in new york
in the audition um room
all over new york city and so it was
really fun to finally work with him
and we did this movie called my fake
fiance for abc family
and we were like you know what we would
be great in a tv show together we should
create something so and i just was like
my only stipulation was i don't want to
play a character that's
got it all together i want to play a
complete nightmare so
uh i got to do that and we got these
great show runners that again we had
amazing writing
staff and a fantastic crew and we had a
lot of fun for five years doing melissa
and joey we did 104 episodes of that one
and uh just had a blast had an absolute
blast and it was my first show in front
of an audience
that is why sabrina and clarissa were
not in front of they were not
traditional sitcoms
they were multicams but they weren't in
front of an audience and so that would
that took me about good
25 episodes to get used to to calm
myself down in front of an audience and
be able to perform
for the cameras not the audience elliot
is my boyfriend
what she said the ladies are her
boyfriend
i heard so you know doing it in front of
an audience is not my favorite way to do
it it is an exciting
fun format for sure but um
i like going to work and doing what i
feel is right
yeah and then going home as opposed to
trying to get up on a friday night
at 5 00 p.m trying to be you know you
work all week long
towards this goal which is starting at 5
p.m on friday night when most people are
going out for happy hour and done with
their work week
you're trying to get amped up to like
get out there and play the big game you
know
like that's not how i work i'm used to
like being up at 6am and like let's do
this and
even if i have to go till 2am right i'll
fight through it but
5pm to have bring all that energy and
try to get a show in in five hours
and then let the audience leave but
they're having pizza and there's
freaking flashing lights and there's a
dj
and you're trying to like remember lines
and and then talk to your cast members
and the writers are coming in with
changes and you're like
can you guys like there's 200 people up
there having a party on a friday night
and i'm trying to work
work here to work so i took a little
getting used to and i'm much better at
it now
but it's still not my favorite way to
work it's so fun to do those live shows
they're definitely a different beast and
i like that i get to mix it up i like
that i get to direct and produce and
do do multi-cam and single cam and i
direct multicam and single cam and like
i
feel doing it i feel very versatile you
are melissa you are indeed and i also
want to take a little trip down memory
lane with you my dear okay
you know we like to do that around here
at e2 it's amazing i mean
i think we're all really shocked we knew
we had a good show but we weren't sure
how good
and now the ratings and the audiences
prove it
what is it like working with these cats
are they giving you any trouble
um i think they're
they they want to do what they want to
do you know i think just like the actors
they're like typical actress they want
to go where they want to go
and you know you can't really bribe them
that easily now but um
they're great they're wonderful and it's
a lot better
carrying a real cat than carrying an
animatronic cat so
you know for a while there i was like oh
i don't want to carry the cat but then
like i carried the animatronic cat for a
scene and i was like
might rather carry the real cat
but you could tell in the beginning of
that that like our show wasn't expected
to do well
we thought it was a great show we
thought it had a lot of potential
especially because i liked shows like
bewitched and i dream of genie so i
thought it
was gonna be like that and it ended up
like that but
everything that was coming out clueless
was the big hit what's going on here
we're giving the park a complete
makeover we're being totally selfless
it was going to be this new show
clueless based on the movie that
everyone loved
and i loved and i was like how are we
going to compete with that and
everything every billboard and
everything was
clueless 8 p.m and then watch sabrina
and then we ended up being higher in the
ratings and
and just kicking butt on friday night
and it was so we were sort of like
oh wow and then beginning of second
season we got picked up for second
season and third season
that wasn't heard of in network
television they pick up 13 at a time
they do not pick up two seasons
at a time and so the crew explained to
me like do you know how rare this
is that we got we know what we're doing
for the next two years no one in
hollywood knows what they're doing for
the next two years
so it was like a huge thing and i was
able to really we were all able to
really like enjoy
every minute on that show every episode
we got to shoot we were like
this is a blessing and we know it and
we're having fun and that's what we did
for seven years
we're thankful that you did and then
here you are now at this stage in your
life
still working diligently always busy but
you are
acting you're directing you're producing
at this point in your life which do you
find the most joy
in i really love directing i feel like
i'm the most creative when i'm directing
i feel like i'm the most in control i
feel like i have the best energy
i'm the most useful because directing is
from the beginning to the end you know
it is
it is reading that script it is picking
that cast it is deciding what the props
look like it's deciding what the
locations are it's deciding the angles
of the camera it's deciding the whole
every aspect of it through editing
through the sound design through the
whole thing but it's also exhausting and
my brain hurts
so i love to switch it up right so
y'all have been married for 17 years yes
three beautiful boys
how do you make it work you are juggling
a lot
personally professionally and then this
thing called life it's not easy um
i i will say it's ups and downs you know
there's definitely not a smooth road um
it's all built on trust like for us it
just started with trust
and and that's never wavered and i think
that
um and look we've had to do therapy and
we've had to go through tough times
where we
hate each other and but we made a
commitment and we stick to it and we
just find those moments we bring
ourselves back to the place where we
fell in love
and we're just gonna keep to our
commitment and keep loving each other
and especially for the kids we're just
gonna keep showing them
good examples of love and that it's not
always valentine's day it's not always
flowers and candy and
and just sparks flying sometimes it's
just uh making it through breakfast
without screaming at each other or
making it through politics when you're
divided in your household
which is not easy um or deciding on
where to live as a family and
it comes with a lot of sacrifices and he
sacrificed his career for mine and
i sacrificed my house in connecticut to
move to nashville and you know so we
um it's about compromise it's about
compromise and it's about
just uh just being along together you
know like when we moved here we don't
know anybody and the kids were like why
are we moving we don't know anybody we
don't know where we're going we don't
know anything about this town
but it was like well we're going
together the five of us will figure it
out and we're really good at making
friends and when it'll be fine we'll be
okay
i love that that's a great outlook so
you've got three boys ranging at ages
from 14 to
eight have any of them had any interest
in wanting to pursue
so they have but only for the wrong
reasons um they want to be rich and
famous
okay and so they think that's the path
uh because they've seen
that their father is a musician and
dropped out of college and i never quite
finished i went for seven years but
never could quite get my degree
so they see that and they're like well
we don't need this education stuff we'll
just do what you guys did
so it's hard to be like no no no
you still need to get your education you
still need to do well in school you
still have to try hard and
and i want them to have i've always
looked for a fallback career my whole
life i wanted something tangible
i wanted something i could go to work i
wanted something i could grow
and like but look what you have grown
you had heartbreak films now like
producing content
i'm assuming that more projects are on
the horizon when they're producing
directing yeah yeah there's actually a
few on the horizon
we're very busy and and now with my kids
like my focus is i've got 10 more years
of them in the house and i want to
really focus on that
so that's what i like about directing
now that i'm directing so much is that i
can kind of
pick and choose the dates a little bit
so that i don't miss birthdays i don't
miss holidays and that kind of thing
you just seem so real
you're grounded you are extremely
talented
thank you but how have you avoided
early on in your career the pitfalls
that we see so many young child
actors experience you know i think some
of it
a big chunk of it has to go to my
parents like the fact that they
raised me to have a good head on my
shoulders to just um and i really think
that i do take a lot of quotes to heart
like things like seize the day like you
know i do try to make sure i know
someday i'm gonna die so i try to live
every day to the fullest and
um and i do think that like a lot of
these cliches kind of hold true and i
think that
my family raised me to sort of be
responsible for myself from my siblings
for the image i put out there
and i grew up in new york also a lot of
it i think i have to give to location
between new york and then working my
first show in florida
i was kept away from the spotlight and
all the kind of glitz and glamour that
can really
rope you in to trouble and i was also
really aware of the fact that
i whether i was on stage at 10 years old
or i was doing clarissa at 14
i was in front of people and i was
expected to behave a certain way and if
i i could have totally been a diva but
where would that get me like if i didn't
know my lines and i came in all sleepy
and grumpy and i
like how that wouldn't be fun nobody
would like me and um
you know i think there's a certain
aspect to actors too that want to be
pleasers you know we want to please
people and
and i wanted to perform i wanted to make
people happy and
and so in order to do that i should
probably be that way too you know and
and why am i going to act like i'm any
better than anyone else just because
i was given certain opportunities or i
was in the right place at the right time
and um and so that never really took
hold on me
and uh and i do give most of the credit
to my parents and
and my city new york yeah for just you
know
trying to keep it real and just be a
working actor not a famous actor well
honey you are the real deal thank you
for having us over and welcome to nash
vegas
thank you a whole week yes we've been
here a week so
and i hear you've got a quite the ring
on your ring doorbell
oh yes what's your time so the sellers
of the house um
decided to put the sabrina theme song as
my doorbell
[Music]
so you guys were the first visitors
we've had here so it was the first time
i heard the doorbell ring
that is genius on their part it's
hilarious i'm gonna have to put on
instagram at some point so
just wait for it welcome home sabrina
it's so weird